[Music]
[Applause]
transition Demarcus Spears ESPN NFL
analyst former defensive end and member
of NFL live every weekday from well 4 to
5 he's got to put up with Dan orlovski
he gets the pleasure of working with
Laura rutage Mina kimes and Ryan Clark
and the big swagu joins us on the
program are the Rams threat
hey Dan hey hey buddy they are they are
man they are the way Matthew Stafford is
playing right now um offensively this
team the eye opener for me was against
Baltimore and what they were able to do
against that defense and the type of
plays that they were able to make and
obviously we know getting Cooper cup
back was huge was a huge infusion of
juice for this offense and I love the
running back Karen Williams who I think
is one of the most underrated players in
this year so um they they fixed a lot of
things I think sea McVey um coaching has
come to the Forefront um last year was
just so bad man injuries um not having a
lot of your your key pieces but this
year he's showing his he's showing why
he's was regarded as one of the better
not only offensive minds but head
coaches in the league this time of the
year you get those teams that it's not
the playoffs but they're playing like
it's the playoffs like every game you
know Buffalo's got to win out yeah now
granted they're a big favorite against
the Chargers the Bengals and Steelers
you know there there's a lot attached to
that as well speaking of the Steelers
Ben rothberger had some critical things
to say about the Steeler way
offensively uh maybe it's not there
anymore uh you know when you start to
point the finger of blame here does it
start at Mike Tomlin that you can have
the Steeler way on defense but not have
it on offense does that make sense yeah
it starts with Mike and you know
obviously he one of my favorite people
because I know him personally but it
starts with him um he know that I don't
hold any punches when it comes to that
you see some of the undisciplined things
some of the lack of effort things and
obviously we coming right off of the
George pickings not doing the damn thing
on the Block uh that could have
potentially turned into a touchdown for
them against the Colts but um I think
Mike would tell you himself it always
starts with him um you know offensively
the offensive coordinator job I think
that was hell ONN too long you could
have made this transition way earlier
you saw that that wasn't going anywhere
um so yeah I think you I mean for as
much as they get paid DP you're damn
right we gonna start with them when we
see problems uh with the team and and
that's who it goes to and then that
doesn't absolve these grown players from
not you know doing the minimal sometimes
you just get beat sometimes you play
teams that are better um but but but
we've seen now this from Deontay Johnson
we saw this from George Pickins we heard
um Naji Harris talk about um be be down
and dejected about what they were doing
offensively so this feels like a
holistic problem and we were talking
about it yesterday on NFL live and
realizing that this is also the second
youngest offense in the NFL so it's not
a lot of leadership on that side of the
ball or not that calming presence that
you would look for or even the presence
to challenge people when they not doing
their job like I was fortunate to be
around a lot of veterans in Dallas a lot
of dudes that would challenge you call
you out and it made me a better Pro um
so I think it is more on Mike T to get
that specific unit doing what they need
to do how often does the defense take
offense when the offense isn't playing
well and say something to the offense or
maybe vice versa how often does that
happen do you think in a locker room it
doesn't happen when they playing bad
because it it it's you know that they're
trying to have success the difference is
when you see effort like the difference
is when you see physicality and I think
that's what TJ and obviously Cam and
Minka Fitzpatrick when you look at the
leaders of this team they not g to go
get into the intricate details of why we
can't run the football or why we don't
have a bunch of yards offensively but
when you see again example George pcking
is not making a block and then you
couple that with the fact that we not
having a lot of success offensively and
we haven't had a lot of success
throughout the year that's when you go
over as a defensive guy and be like man
what the hell wrong with y'all yeah
though look what you saw DP is the that
that is what happens before players only
meetings those type of things are what
what give the validity to say hey we
kicking the coaches out and the coaches
have to do their job but accountability
in the NFL and any good team that I've
ever been a part of the players took
more accountability than having a coach
have to say something about is sha
McDermot coaching for his
job um I think this last little
Resurgence no um this a crazy League
though DP we know how crazy it is man um
if they don't make the playoffs if they
don't make the playoffs it's going to be
a real conversation about if he's the
guy going forward I really believe that
and that that because of the tremendous
amount of success that Buffalo has had
playoff wise and Josh Allen has played
really really well even though you know
the firing of offensive coordinator the
firing of a defensive coordinator or or
the leave of absence of Lesley F Frasier
I think if this team do go to the
playoffs and I talked about it earlier
this year is that this the NFL now is
about Windows and if yours is open you
better you better try to make it happen
you better at least get there right like
if they if they miss the playoffs think
about this DP if the Buffalo Bills
missed the playoffs we are removed two
years away from saying this was one of
the best teams if not the best team in
football and now you suffer injuries
with Matt Milano you got travius Wright
injuries as well you look you look at
the offensive side Stefon digs has been
up and down about his excitement or
enjoyment about being there um Joe Brady
is the best thing that happened to this
team in the last few weeks yeah because
he's calling an offense that doesn't put
everything on Josh and some of those
have translated into Wis um I hate to
say it but I think so um now it would it
would be it would still be surprising DP
if they fired Shan mcder um to me but it
wouldn't be something that I'm like ah
that there's no basis for that it would
just be to change direction and change
course and hopefully get you over the
top he's Marcus Spears you can see him
Monday through Friday NFL live at 4
Eastern with Laura rutage me to K St off
and Ryan Clark when you were with the
Cowboys how aware are you when you go
out like everything you do when you're a
cowboy in that town as opposed to some
other place that you played yeah it's
crazy I I bet it's not as bad DP as like
a Green Bay or a buffalo okay right
because of the
vicinity um but there is a lore to to
being a cowboy man like I still eat free
around here I still get people calling
me to do I still make money off the fact
that I played for the Cowboys so it's
one of those things where look this city
was the Second City I lived in um my
entire life right I grew up in Baton
Rouge Louisiana was there all the way
throughout college and and and got
drafted obviously in Dallas so this is
home for me um Beyond Baton Rouge which
is my heart and my home where I where I
learned everything but uh this city has
been abs absolutely amazing now
obviously the perks come with the fact
that you were drafted by the Cowboys and
uh people recognize you and they want to
be a part and the so and attached but
you ain't you ain't like Troy Eggman on
Monday Night Football that got something
to do with the c Dallas Cowboys I'm o
ESPN that got something to do with
playing for the Dallas Cowboys it's not
just about local like the local people
love us and they tell us every every
chance they get but the national
presence that you have when you play for
the Cowboys as well is uh I think Second
To None I mean we all over the media
that ain't no coincidence DP okay you
you think you think from your career
that you played for the Dallas Cowboys
to be honest like all of the success
that you had you think you played for
the Cowboys yeah backup tight end I was
there for a few years yeah and and a
backup punter as well punter yeah um I
want you to tell me what Tua is
referring to uh Marvin if we could play
Tua Tonga
vioa I keep receipts we all we all have
have have a way of how we do things but
like all the narratives about it I am
yeah sure I am only good with tyreen i
that you're right I am that is the only
time I am at my best um you're right I'm
only good when jaylen's in I I I could
care less about it like sure uh if
Jaylen and those guys aren out like I'm
only as good as Raheem moard allows me
to be like that's that's what the
narrative needs to be and we're able to
win games and we're able to go where we
want to go as a team I am the worst
football player if that's what you want
like I don't care like I really
don't I I like that he cares he says he
doesn't care but he cares tremendous
okay does he have a legitimate gripe
here
um no I mean I I think if you if DP we
always we always got to
separate
um I don't want to even say fans and
people that actually watch the game in
detail Tua can play Tu is a really good
quarterback very accurate um great with
ball placement The Narrative about his
arm strength I never bought into it
because I saw him play at Alabama and I
saw him throw beautiful uh deep deep
passes down the field um I think the The
Narrative on Tua is with all of this
Talent surrounding you are you going or
where do you all in that order this same
conversation that I have about Brock P
right everybody talk everybody thinks
that you mad or you hating or you can't
don't think these dudes can play when
you have a legitimate argument around
them like DP honestly when you walk into
the stadium and you're about to play the
Miami Dolphins who the hell do you think
the defensive plan starts with Tyreek it
starts with Tyreek Hill yeah like that
is the narrative that's starting to make
all of these quarterbacks think or all
or people in general think that if you
don't say that they the best quarterback
or that that it's going it's it's like
they can't play at all like Brock pie I
was on uh get up the other day Brock py
is playing out of his mind he's
absolutely elevated what this San
Francisco 49ers team can do that ain't
the first person you think about when
you walk in the stadium and you playing
against the 49ers like you and you got
to understand when I come from a
defensive perspective I come from a
perspective of sitting in in a facility
for five days a week game planning on
who do we have to make sure we take care
of if we gonna have the best chance to
win this game you know who people saying
that is for the 49ers Christian mcaffrey
just like people saying Tyreek Hill is
the guy for the Miami Dolphins so when
do you get to Tua right when I go to
Baltimore Lamar Jackson is first on that
list when I go to Kansas City Patrick
Mahomes is First on on that list when I
go to Buffalo Josh Allen the first
person you got to take care of when you
go to Green Bay Aaron Rogers would have
killed us if he wasn't the first person
we had to decide that we were gonna take
care of so those are that is how I
determine when you start talking about
quarterbacks okay but who's your MVP
then my MVP is Lamar Jackson okay yeah
like like I have because first of all DP
I have a a flaw okay this is my
I gotta admit it my flaw is you got one
okay I got I got one just one we all
gotta have one yeah you know um Lamar
Jackson to
me is in a in a rare category if it's
not for Patrick Mahomes and you can also
put Josh Allen in this category it
should have been a revolving door around
those three for League MVP right because
when I think of most valuable Aaron
Rogers obviously in that and he won them
so I'm I omitted him because he won two
of them um DP tell me who's been more
valuable to their team outside of
Patrick Mahomes is the only argument and
obviously we talking about Aaron Rogers
but he won him who's been more valuable
to their team outside Lamar Jackson yeah
I've said for a while now that no team
ask more of their quarterback than
Baltimore does with Lamar jckson and you
got people that will argue Buffalo and
they got a legitimate argument he
already won is MVP and you know how this
goes in the media we we'd love to have a
new story we want to move on that's why
we're trying to get Dak in there Brock
pie in there you know even Tyreek Hill
maccaffrey in there and it's not it's
not just us DP they do it in basketball
LeBron should have won at least two more
MVPs in basketball um so look Brock P
numbers what he's done absolutely should
be in the MVP conversation and I got him
too
because you just can't deny the well
what if he looks great on Monday night
against the Ravens and Lamar Jackson
then you moving past Lamar Jackson okay
but if Lamar wins that game in a win he
has to win the game yeah if Lamar wins
that game then all of a sudden he's your
favorite yeah because if Lamar is my
favorite now but if Lamar wins that game
we he I guarantee you he's going to be
who we walk away saying was the best
player on the field if San Francisco
wins it we ain't going to walk away
saying Brock P was the best player on
the
field all right I love Youk people get
mad at me for that man I love bro I have
watched I have watched Brock py snap
after snap after snap I'm not like Dan I
haven't seen every snap Dan orlovski but
I've seen enough to know how much he's
impacting the success of this football
team my only thing is this when you
didn't have two guys you went 0 and
three and average 17 points a game Lamar
Jackson lost Mark Andrews they rolling
all right he's lost offensive lineman
they rolling he just lost his probably
most explosive running back yeah he's
still Gonna Roll we don't have that same
type of sentiment you know so hey now
last part on this MVP
conversation if Josh Allen didn't throw
so many interceptions he'd probably be
the leader in the
clubhouse they have to make the playoffs
uh
hey thank you for coming on this year we
appreciate it Merry Christmas to you man
Merry Christmas to you brother um send
me some steaks I don't know if we're
gonna be able to do meat Frid come up
just if you don't do it now do it in the
off where are you where are you again
tell me again I'm about an hour from
Bristol oh okay yeah yeah we'll do me
Friday Friday hard man because I'm
always home I'm like 20 minutes from
orlovski oh that's why you that's why
you don't like him why because you too
close to him he gets on your nerves oh I
just like guys who play the position
really well yeah I got you well we we
the same and
every thank you
Marcus that's Marcus Spears we'll take a
break we're back after this